et à votre avis combien faudrait-il de
couches de tapisserie pour que les deux
murs se touchent
c'est comme ça je préfère les fumeurs de
cannabis dans la Seine
il y en a qui sont là ah ouais bon
délire on est là
allez je me lance je me lance
vas-y lance-toi et coupe tes dreads
non mais je passe souvent des questions
comme ça quand je me fais chier et c'est
les gens qui ont une tâche de vin sur le
visage genre Jean-Luc Reichmann ou
Gorbatchev est-ce que est-ce qu'ils ont
déjà pensé à mettre du sel dessus
il y a 80000 se repositif en France et
2000 qui ne savent pas pourquoi on leur
dit pas
faut-il mettre une majuscule après un
émoticône
pour ceux qui ont encore un doute dans
la salle je prends de la drogue